hey guys sorry for the delay it was my
fault blame teh hashtag went a pretty
standard me Eric that's Joey
hello that can only really mean one
thing it usually means overwatch and
that's what you guys are getting today I
should have moved the picture-in-picture
I'll do that in a second but doom fist
is finally like officially out out like
not PTR real and I'm sure some of you've
played him because he's been out since
last week but you know anytime I can
give Joey a chance to play Doom fist I
figured why not so now you can go
through all his cool stuff his a
highlight I think they were released
like a little while ago on PTR actually
mm-hmm won't go too much into it but you
just take a look real quick
and there's other patch notes as well
that we can go through and like loop box
updates things like that so we'll talk
about those as we go but really
appreciate you guys all tuning in and
waiting for us there for a little bit if
you haven't followed like and subscribed
to our channel make sure you guys do
that because you know we go live every
day at 11 a.m. with our live streams and
then we have a cool VOD content
I think Joey's already made doom fists
hero guide so if you want to learn the
ins and outs of doofus you know
obviously check that out and he's also
made like kind of like a quick gameplay
clip of ways to counter doom fist will
also try to showcase some of those
things today
of course as someone mentioned I think
cyborg man in YouTube chat you can't
play doom fist currently in competitive
but you can play him in you know arcade
quick play so why don't you hop in a
game yes sure let's see we can actually
get him that's good right yeah quick
we'll see we will see so let's see for
arcade mode that got the 6v6 doomed this
elimination mode locked well okay yes
okay for quick play okay let's go
quickly as look back it I was gonna buy
one of the highlight intros
cuz feelin a play of the game yeah also
the highlight intros there's like
options right there's like oh there's an
update to the highlighting yeah well
alright let's see if I can get them he's
the first one on the list so nope are
they sorry there's our highlight options
not highlighting show off oh there we go
Adam was easy if doom fist take and try
it out hard counter you got it like one
man do you think they will nerf doom
fist I mean they kind of already did in
PTR oh yeah
I haven't played as much doofus so like
I know you've been playing him a little
bit yeah does he feel more balanced from
that time or is it about the same and it
I think it's I think it's about the same
yes learning thing or in the beginning
fling every time we go on the PTR to
play a new hero it's always like you and
then 11 other ones of the same character
so everyone just kind of going all out
they're not really like trying to avoid
people or try and use like defensive
strategies and whatnot so it's always
gonna feel like a little bit overpowered
at first I think yeah but what I
remember them saying is that they derped
his distance on the rocket punch like
slightly me like was it 20% but it's
still it still goes really fast and
really far though and then the the slam
right you can't really got exactly what
it was but I think the because you told
me like even the uppercut moves slightly
different right let's see the upper
coats oh no it's the same same is that
um for the slam you can't target
something above you oh so you can't try
it use it to like jump oh I have like an
arc or a climb you can still jump away
with it but it has to be like below
that's kind of cool they added a little
a numerical value Lance know for this
for the slam okay already
oh so much help that's okay you're gonna
gain health 150 and then you can cancel
it of course just key
here but yeah I'll be checking out chat
so you know obviously if you guys have
questions or what you knew ask yeah he
was waiting for me so but yeah I mean
it's cool to get another offensive hero
I think there was the longest time where
we thought that you know he was gonna be
a tank so about those hard counters I
think bastions if he's probably yeah but
you could if he didn't see you drop down
you could have punched him right I don't
know if it would be enough for like even
if I hit him in the back but he was near
a wall though you know and that doesn't
more than yeah Ashton is not okay oh no
I'm out man you guys are getting pushed
I'm gonna die aside working man I'm
saying he can one punch a lot of heroes
it's really annoying I mean boy charge
full charge into a wall like that anyone
under like 250 or if they have 200
health they might might go down pretty
easily but the caveat is that you have
to push him into it like see like that
was what three safety so far has been
going so well yeah that bastion yeah see
this cyborg man saying fashion is
definitely a deal discounters yeah
definitely it appears that way
it definitely appears like I probably
knows Oh third birthday
kind of there's a bunch of hero updates
to in this patch like divas defensive
matrix she has new sound effects voice
lines they go through a bunch of um
Genji new sound effects and voice lines
oh he died
all right so you guys have you guys have
taken the point now it's good I can't
reach hold her down though
oh hello dad just stand there for us
over no Canon she like gave up I got my
old meteor and make it up there you
probably used to be able to yeah I'm
schooling you strike up from yeah
they'll never they'll never know Oh
someone's already back there with them
who's that you punched the wall you
scared her oh right hard enough
this charge not for you from punching or
does it still light into the sky um if
they hit each other I think they both
just fall down okay it's kind of like
when the Reinhardt charges another
Reinhardt I guess all right stick with
my team this time what's that Bob Jones
welcome to chat
doofus does have some hops I know you
like rocket punch into the room and then
meteor slam where's it gonna happen
fashion is it gonna be you yeah it's
gonna be you it's okay we got rid of the
bastion there's that sacrifice myself
favorite doom skin this one really
really good yeah I really like it it's
only 250 right that's only 250 well I do
like the one that looks like what Jack
Jack Tekken yeah it's like that kind of
looks like familiar kinda looks like gun
Jack the one Joey's wearing is the best
of you you know what I mess with this
guy
I need to find like good spots to like
wait for people just need to do what you
did to that Honda Oh way back when I
like charging and waiting from around
the corner that was probably the best
the pinnacle yeah we do have a a widow
on our team I can see you right now
what's up Gehrig on like a Reinhart or
something this is one winsome and he got
Azaria somewhere ow
yeah we need to get the payload moving
that's right
you heard it right oh that's rap known
to the counters I'm alive of life Oh
it's so bad it wasn't work okay there we
go yeah didn't do anything
what's up reh gaming how are you doing
hello topic welcome to the stream and
potato for life
potato potato you like games
yeah we like games sooo games so Ryan
alright got a buff rocket hammer his
swing speeds been increased by oh yeah
that's right
and Zarya is graviton surge now disables
mobility that's like one of the best
changes I think they could get her for
her oh oh here you go and you got meteor
Dan I'm gonna call media campus what
happened
you got grenaded oh I got tired oh we
got tired yeah that's fine I guess
will there be another Summer Games event
or not yeah actually I'm pretty sure
there's going to be some people found
some awesome stuff was a voice lines or
like actual like skins you know I'm not
sure you would know better than I would
oh good but if they have it we will do
it of course it should be assuming like
within this okay we're so crazy use it
are you gonna use the alt to get out oh
can you do that that killed off a lot of
people your whole team said - eye candy
what guys
All Right see ya am I gonna go with him
I'll do it I'm outta here
I meant to do the alt at least scatter
them all oh you're gonna go challenge
that most of my team is out there so I
go back in oh he's got him got his toes
all right man maybe this will just be
like the last payload we're like you
guys got like pretty shut down oh yeah
just for you Reinhardt you don't get to
go to the front of the queue here and
this fashion is doing worse legit the
junker is President on fire
Lloyd can we somehow we've been pushing
it I feel like we haven't been doing
much but that might just be me yeah well
you're you're doing some Yolo punkin man
I mean here we go oh no watch out junker
Oh use it already on the Winston I don't
know how you're gonna push the bastion
off just gonna stay right here
gave you a bubble god she's got my feet
your feet oh yes yeah I'm like oh they
nobody has anything rip the dream is
dead round one of the new fish dream
goodbye cruel world it's true of course
it was the bastion of course I'll repair
myself right during the res the trip
okay
don't like more quad look like the quad
sure 37 eliminations jeez what a shred
76% kill participation well he was at
every spot hiding behind the Rhinehart
as he should be
mind boggling well yeah if you guys have
any questions for Joey
he's pretty knowledgeable about dentists
as I mentioned earlier he's put out a
hero guide it's pretty informative if
you wanna learn about how to play doom
fists that is a good way to learn little
truck I'll keep going with them see all
right I like the perseverance that's
what it's all about defense you might be
better on defense
maybe you'll get more of those surprise
attacks maybe we'll have to see I'll
take your word for it mostly the same
team looks like you got a May instead of
Azaria this time May all day is what I
like to say
see just out that uh uppercut in to the
slim go it's still pretty still pretty
far yeah it's like a Winston jump it
always pretty much if light is like it
wasn't jumping except you get a little
bit higher because of the right like the
uppercut yeah more vertical yeah but
it's not as good as it was in PTR yes I
remember is like you're able to like I
was like launch myself really far and I
think that's fair I mean you still have
a tool to get away yeah more like Reaper
all day actually the funny thing is I
Lee because there's word Dave's doing
dave druid in the UK is gonna do
overwatch feature soon and I was looking
at my heroes played and Roadhog is
actually my most played hero really yeah
and then followed by Reaper and then May
what is this oh good so it's pretty
interesting you know we release yeah
there's 500 all hair on it late timeline
its the ERISA doom fist Symetra and
there's two more that I can't
Ilana really kept on ax what am I
missing
that's new we're the for new here some
breakfast yes opera so those four and
Symetra are the five that I have never
played a minute of and then guess who my
next like who would be the lowest
actually like played like minutes like
played minutes of that person but very
very few who do you think that is I
don't know oh he's getting healed over
see of course it's a widow no it's
actually shocking because that girl is
pretty good
it's not far oh don't run out
Kinji nope so go through all the
bastions No
merci Lucio I play Lucio and mercy sort
of not Hanzo not Reinhart not where is
my team they're all bunched up back here
at the spawn oh my this guy right here
though nice and get the help that's
great yeah you guys can keep guessing
probably not gonna get it no geez is the
Yolo
I gotta stop doing that Yolo life
apparently QR nope
and when do you think the next Blizzard
cinematic will be released hard to say I
mean they just came out with doom face
so it probably won't be for a little
while some I guess but they they have a
well okay they had the oh so like yeah I
guess that's true
it could be anything because it's just
story related right you don't always
have to be like yeah at least we are the
better doom fist if there's anything I
need a loader stop the payload I love
cod alright why you select on a lot no
not getting through me
it's got the sacrifice life
did you actually hit her oh let's see I
don't think so oh my god stopped midair
it's actually McCree guys really yeah I
don't have that skill shot with the hand
creams I'm all about that easy life I
feel like I'm getting better every like
I've been playing them a lot oh man
there's health in there if you need it
nope okay that doesn't launch him up
does not knock him off he just kind of
stays there come on you gotta do work
see this is the thing about oh he's got
golden that just means he's saved luck
yeah or saved up oh meteor strike oh
yeah you show him who the doofus is you
sure I was gonna say yeah that's the
problem with Widow is her I was having
this conversation with I didn't feel
like it was the UK guys because they
play a lot of overwash together yeah
it's like if you pick Widow you better
do a good job because she's useless if
you don't he got it again or all of this
one
there I am feel like it's day one uh but
yeah went back to my my widow thing it's
like if you if you pick widow you better
be good with her because it's like man
does it does it really hurt your team
when you don't have a solid Widow yeah
cuz she's basically like a waste of
space
let's see okay so over all modes who's
my least do oh there's Widow
oh wait a 41 minutes total ever I think
most of that was in like arcade mode
words or just random random getting her
yeah is like Torbjorn bashing so growing
zoria nice this this chart makes mine
look terrible but I stopped playing a
long time ago goob knows that and doing
this little dude fist you're gonna get
to hit get him up there there are 40
hours it might take a while it took me a
year a year for Zarya geez only 247
hours played feels like more 15 1800 yes
okay I could do that he's sweaty and
salty for old man tape yeah I think it
would just if they never came out with
competitive mode I probably would've
played a lot more competitive mode
definitely made me salty it gave me the
like my dota 2 flashbacks cuz I played a
lot of dota in college yeah it was fun
cuz I was playing with my roommates and
stuff like that and it was great and
then dota 2 came out and I was like oh
like God tried playing that again right
and then I just couldn't do it I just I
got so salty on the train yeah games are
like 40 minutes it wasn't like I had 41
to spend anymore and it was just like 40
minutes of well like 25 minutes of salt
it's like why would you like know that
you're losing the entire case exactly
and there was like and back then there
wasn't like oh let's vote to concede but
we don't really know I believe there is
now well I I think it's kind of like
League where you have to have like
everyone say
Liz James hello asking Joey what color
would you describe doing fist is what
colored yeah he's golden crispy Bob
Jones saying he doesn't play competitive
overwatch at all I mean that's fair it's
like it is definitely a struggle
especially if you solo play I think that
that could be pretty difficult obviously
but you know some people persevere I
spent many men much time soloqueue and
competitive alright yeah this just takes
perseverance so yeah I forgot to say
hello to the people in periscope thank
you guys for tuning in and watching on
Twitter I suppose we appreciate you guys
being with us me and Joey
while we stream some pots doom fist
action gutter got her yeah just like
Nick turd with the hand cannons hot 18
points of damage
yeah you definitely need that team
synergy has good said it helps a lot it
it makes the experience a lot better too
I feel like or worse depending how you
look at it because some people get salty
I do
and get mad at people golden fist II
question mark not now right now we've
got the I don't know I
what's the skin called their name yeah
good night tracer what's the second time
I don't think she ran into me there so
just a raw
yeah take that you turn it no guilt
about someone finished off what was
probably uh oh she's ready she's asking
for it
jump in the back package now you're
saying our friend agent Ellen needs to
be carried we don't and we actually
don't have a healer
oh wait oh we got a got a when did he
come in and who did you replace someone
on your team that left oh you got it you
got it soldier heal that you know yeah
that's good
oh man Joker I just got triple o he
carries you my bed my bed
all right goobers get in the cage that's
that's pretty standard to be honest
pretty standard whoa hello
all right you got the heels on you it's
good thank you
he's got the journey that's a Wukong
skin pack
I still think nutcrackers in the odd is
the best he's the best yeah I bought
that one with gold I had to do they not
have a team
well the diva oh they're just chillin in
the back yeah they're really not doing
much they don't have a healer they just
kind of have a May and a widow for some
reason also is just a reminder guys
don't forget we have lobby tomorrow who
is a pretty good no and then Thursday we
got Triforce master mode with Rob and
Peter of course and then Friday we got
Joey okay you picked up a health I was
like oh man what that was a one life and
oh no so when someone being around
payload they were and then they heard it
and then ran away they're gonna be doing
PlayStation 1 games I think do you guys
test that yet I think we will do that
test it tomorrow okay although I think
John Luke has his framemeister now yeah
so as long as that works yeah yeah yeah
because that has HDMI
something something exploded those divas
but they're gonna be playing some I
think ps1 Disney games yeah he won -
that's a real really good skin oh you
watch it but yeah they're gonna be
playing Disney at ps1 games on and on
they're kind of new live streaming game
dump where they go through our game
library and check out some of those hot
fun games from the library figure to go
she's not dead
then with my rock come on
Oh smart Oh God that's a new spot or for
me I've never seen ya I've never seen
him there she's working well cuz no
one's yeah no one's see that's a good
Widow yeah he's getting it done it's a
mystery new show too bad he's got
spoiled Ivan
I've been pimping it since like two
weeks ago because they were supposed to
do it like last week and then we got an
alternate thing with the joy con of
cooking mmm
well that title sweet delicious joy con
of cooking Oh what they have a run hard
now yes they have a right heart sad
times for you all right we got meteor
slang again that's pretty fast actually
I don't feel like you've done that much
since the last one what do you mean like
you got your super back foot I mean yeah
I think so he's in a corridor oops nice
Oh back into the spoiling combo all the
right arts here oh there's no shield for
you that was a good run that was good
run that's what three kills you altered
the maid then you finished off the
soldier and then Reinhardt thought he
could walk in come here you join the
party
James it'll be kind of retro II it
depends I guess I can't say that it'll
be like that every week but I'm sure
there will be playing some some older
it's true
oh I can't get up there oh you just
discharged yeah see ya finish him off
haha oh [ __ ]
no you got the life oh he wasted it
super you're still alive got you still
it was weird like yeah I was like in the
air animation but you still got hammered
down I don't know that's a weird trade
nice Oh
what what pixel Oh
special delivery right to your doorstep
he's like thanks for jumping right at me
oh she missed it twice holy head a
little bit more help tough times tough
times it's doom fist right now pin me
harder daddy Ryan our picture-in-picture
huh that's actually not that bad it's
just your Hulk
yeah it's not the end of the list no I
can move I can move it
[Music]
the widowed here right now top rights
fine to you right I would say top of
left
okay this top right guys don't mind me
up don't decide oh that was you just
Widow
I'll let their alright Joey didn't get
to warm up so I'll say that the first
game was kind of a wash and now he's
gonna reach his final form will see some
I guarantee in anything near a type of
form he's gonna reach some type of form
guys there we go
I miss it Here I am trying to move us
what I'm not sure what I punch but I all
right now you can see new faces what's a
better map review face anything with
like narrow corridors I guess let's see
what would be good I would think Kings
Road was pretty good what well I mean
for you together well yeah that was well
that was a personal name for like
defense and with not a bastion there
may all like oh you got the widow's you
got the widow hacks or you have meteor
slam - oh yeah oh yeah like land it on
like you got that man I like land it on
top of the the wall out of the wall oh
yeah I got boy somehow good well cuz the
may had just popped out yeah and then
the Winston was walking up to try to get
to the pelota thing poop chute and
answer any any spot but uh he was
bastard
all right map packs or aimbot my
favorite kind
oh wait and he didn't do it oh he's
going to right doesn't look like it he
got a double got triple right he's got a
you know I love it when the plate guy
was played the game left the game was
even watching yeah I was pretty pretty
man pretty man you guys are just tuning
in we're checking out doofus who's
finally out official no longer in PTR
he's been out for a couple days it's
been out since last week but we didn't
have a chance to play him so you know I
figured Tuesday was up wasn't a really
big game releases this week figured I'd
let Joey play some overwatch because it
likes the overwatch so thank you guys
all for tuning in the live stream every
day at 11 a.m. oh I didn't know you had
that skin which one this one
none of the rooster the year the roost
for Bastien yeah I missed the year of
the rooster um junk rat that was the one
that wants someone hasn't I feel like I
haven't run into me other tau I guess
I'll just go I'll just keep on going
with ya got a lot of warnings over here
no healers no tanks you also have too
many snipers too many defense so yeah
every day I love an AM
live streaming so cut check it out
you guys haven't subscribed ready
obviously or like they're followed on
switches that also helps and thank you
to the people tuning in on Twitter
appreciate you guys check over to
Twitter we're on Twitter - yeah nice
game so on Twitter if you haven't fall
against about Twitter you should do that
in case we go live obviously and also
because we do giveaways every now and
then for like you know beta codes and
all that fun stuff so
hi I'm Bolin gaming I'm sad right now
for obvious reasons that you would
understand yeah
has anyone had played anything other
than Futurama song I know there's like
nothing I don't think anyone that one
heck of a team comp there's this
philanthropy I know right look at that
15.com all offense a some people say the
best defense is a great offense that's
the name of his ability yep I meant to
do oh [ __ ]
I'm okay it's funny because that was one
of your counters kind of yeah cuz you
can't you can't rock a punch or although
I always I always laugh when a I trap
like a Reaper in that trap and he turns
into a ghost and you just but he's still
stuck there stuck there but you can't do
damage don't lie quiet if your ghost how
can you still get trapped in that thing
that's bad you see - Jeff at Caplin that
Daddy Jeff you are a crazy man
other doofus other is yeah hey there
he's gone he's got it he's got the
legendary skin not the cool one though
like oh he feels like the mole what not
okay there is the widow racer by the way
yeah yeah I hear the new Maeda is two
snipers minimum come on get out of here
summer games yeah love blitz unit I
think Joey had mentioned that and
someone else in chat I mentioned it
earlier that there might have been some
you know maybe some data mines stuff or
something
wouldn't be shocked they do if that's
all the time so okay pick them pick them
with the oh here okay feeling good I'm
feeling good about this old old do kids
would have been able to
oh he was he was totally in the air too
so I thought he was gonna fall at the
same rate did he fall off the mat I
don't know it looks like oh yeah that's
what that was he was like in the air I
don't know but either buggy or he fell
off in that why here we go the planks
the big flanks baby big plays we're
going with some big sneaky plays there's
no one here nobody here no sneaky plays
okay maybe you go that way yeah here we
go here we go we're going for the sneaky
plays part two
do you think there would be an overwatch
to ask Bob Jones probably not for a
while no no no no no no oh you almost
killed him come on Hans oh he's
literally Rigo was amazed or always me
God I had to do is touch him I'll watch
out for those traps yeah I look down
it's like when you're walking on kind of
uneven pavement you should always like
have your peripherals down here on case
you just eat a pothole or something you
don't want to be that person
or that girl that breaks her heel or
something but back to your overwatch to
question I don't think that'll happen
for a while because they'll just keep
adding heroes and content instead so
there's not really a need to gum cryo
says I expected him to look a lot like a
mr. t mr. t not like this
what not like this thank you for him to
come down see that he waited meteor
smash them just for the SN giggles of it
they could have maybe did ask in if
anything we all thought he would be
Terry Crews and that never came to
deliver I kind of like that they didn't
use him I don't know maybe I'm in the
minority here but like the whole thing
of just beat like it being expected like
I like how they created the character
like just on his own instead of being
like yeah cuz if he did have Terry
Cruz's voice you would just think about
that the entire time like playing him
but that's the great part of it oh I
just want to be like his own thing I
don't know okay how about this how do
what's up
I know Louisa holla chat decide on that
I think I think it would've been cool to
have Terry Crews for voice lines and
stuff like that I don't know I think
it's he doesn't necessarily have to be
like the character model or whatever but
it would have been cool to have at least
voice lines I feel like yeah okay so far
I can at least definitively say in a 1v1
doom fist we have had the upper hand
which is the most important part oh the
upper hand they don't they don't know
about that uh stuck under here what is
this fortnight
now you got diva in here right now I
just need to get her out of there
nope she's nursing it oh I would have
just went into that room you might need
to okay were they at you got them all
hacks you got nobody hit oh no I'm just
gonna push the payload may all your
mails on the payload
oh he's he gonna meteor strike use yep
no where is everyone
given payload it appears he had the
upper hand that time got anyone forgot
the junk rash he's gonna make it
yeah oh gosh this is what happens when
you don't play any dealer oh no we don't
well he's no anymore for shame for shame
this guy again
he was pretty good though yeah
it's getting free rein here yeah we're
coming at me
okay there's oh that's very sad should
we do it 6v6 doom fist elimination I do
it why not for the lulz
oh yeah one of the new updates to this
patch is the the highlight menu and so
that you can actually like save
highlights okay yeah any point during
the match so that it's not just the ones
that they save for you mhm
so you just press like f9 and no you can
save like up to three per match and then
you kill in this menu can export it at
like any resolution as well yeah so you
can record at 720 but like you can then
you can export it later at 4k if you
want mm-hmm what's up bunny boy lay what
put me back in alright let's get a hot
skin we've got some normal doom fists
thank you probably see with everyone
else and then charges in
well this isn't this is it yeah I was
gonna say this is one of those maps he's
just gonna camp that tunnel wait for one
to show someone to show up and then
rocket punch right this is the mallanna
god he's dead
your only hope oh we got one to mow on
us
you got to mow unnies you voted for Dave
Chappelle should do this he's a little
oh he is a little jacked
yeah Dave Chappelle yeah he's like
buffer well I don't know if he still is
but uh last time I saw him he was like
pretty like buff for Dave Chappelle
you're used to like skinny funny Dave
now he's like kind of like buff funny
Chappelle or like cut you're not like
really like big yeah show them that I'll
play oh yeah oh
oh my god you got the Bree yeah got
three limbs ghetto get him oh no no
that's the bait he baited him into the I
think you know yo
does he though no no this guy's go right
no it's one on two but that guy's got to
be low on health the Oz he's got a
silver portrait he knows what he's doing
okay okay
Oh cooldowns are all gone that's where
he's got a hope to jump over him only
okay it's this team of do fists has
gotten lucky the other team at least
that round I feel like Joey's gotta
export he's got an export yep that's
what I'm talking about you gotta wait
you gotta you know play that hot waiting
game
you gotta get there yeah don't run from
above I guess losing alright it's 2 V 2
to V 100 someone just left that's why
he's guessing game pecs Oh desk or
whatever that oh the pole is for voice
acting that's very oh that guy is just
added picture man basic basic doofus
you can also capture this any play of
the game you can cap out all their play
again yeah these guys damn salt are you
in the mind she Joey the what are you in
the mind the salt mines right now a
little bit I'll bet that's fair
these are all the custom games you could
join oh my a creep ain't ball one punch
man one punch
Friday the 13th yeah
one punch equals one killer cause one
alt that seems crazy hide-and-seek 500%
everything this one the upgrade game is
that like a PV evening
yeah okay there's a law so a lot of what
you're thinking about some people they
just like a just random things and open
it up for everyone yeah take a long time
to find a game here over a minute oh
there oh okay as we as speak of the
devil bunny my home town right yeah
that's why it's all yellow and green
behind us that was all point did we use
that for like Brazil at one point we did
it for ERISA ERISA or is it Arisa
Orvis I think it's all ERISA ERISA okay
or so later elects loss I might have
been a while ago I don't know though
hard to say okay yeah he learnt in tank
good oh so we're actually playing a prop
okay yeah well I did this how do we know
that
yeah destroy everything everything
suitcases oh you try to block it
thanks all right Joey this is this match
might be your last we'll see all right
remember guys thank you guys for tuning
in on its which YouTube game spot and
here's go don't tell me we there's still
that other Widow okay it's a different
one but still keep my head out for like
a second and she's there don't forget we
stream every day at 11 a.m. so please
like Paul subscribe all that good stuff
so you guys can get notified for that
tomorrow come on the lobby as we get
trapped by Joe Kratts hmm up top oh no
he left that there okay when he also
like jumped back up I heard junk rats
actually getting some buffs
really they're like planning on it
apparently did they mention what it was
they said something like just well they
adjusted the UH like the damage like put
more damage on the trap Oh decrease the
cooldown on the the mine so that he has
like better mobility did they nerfed any
are they thinking about nerfing any of
the grenades
oh I think they're looking to damage a
little bit but decreasing the cooldown
Defra widow to somewhere well she's all
the way over there
for life Road hogs playing Hans oh
that's weird
where the counter chefs right the
counter shots are in his video on
YouTube he also did a hero guide if you
guys haven't checked it out we're doing
this pretty good guys so you guys
definitely check that out
click that turret slam down watch your
butt seat seat up there we go don't step
in one of those spinning Oh can't charge
up I think tracer is pretty good against
doing this as well because I know in the
hallway
all right do some connections is that
just your normal punch that's the the
right click oh fast yeah it's just like
you can do it a really quick that's a
waiter oh no I saw that tranquility
thank you he's out of tranquility you
should get the hell out I feel like yeah
that thing is not just feel like it
doesn't go as high with the UH with the
change the slam okay because you're
trying to aim you I don't know points
apple pie oh you're so dead
it's High Noon okay can't get me from
here
oh he boosted someone four percent right
I'll have it wonderful how far do you
think I can go from the spawn I don't
want to go to reason I don't think it's
gonna reach not from here such a long
yeah I got like five only five seconds
or something
Oh
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
all the tires still wears it you think
you would have died if you smashed the
tire if I like punched it yeah if you
came down and meteor strike the tires
actually it'd be okay oh so crazy so
much Joey's plays making nervous no are
you oh oh god if she went into the
dragon oh come on oh no guide though oh
I thought you were gonna get him as he
landed that would be real sick Oh watch
out for the trap there's a trap on that
[Music]
we've got five minutes to escort it four
meters oh yeah yeah I did
back in don't god where's our tank what
are you doing please don't walk out
there
that's their so everything I'm gonna go
[Applause]
always wanted 81% I'll have my old up
soon watch they hold this biggest hold
in game sought last June history holds
the line on the door hold the door
it's a good time to plug game swag
University guys have checked out case by
universe you guys should check them out
they cover all our TV shows
entertainment movies all that stuff Mike
Rouge ow I'm sorry if I butchered her
last name man he just joined on he's
been writing some reviews of movies got
buddy Hutton Ryan Greg chasse T as well
doing you know different recaps for
shows got the UK folks of course doing
GameSpot of thrones should definitely
check them out they're doing some cool
stuff like this meteor smash die Widow
sorry fellas were like oh yeah baby hand
cam baby where's it oh no not the
payload come on guys okay we're good we
go
Oh what free gone the way always so
close to die nice apple pie
okay okay okay I'm gonna punch it
wherever oh never mind
where was it it's behind I think oh it
was right there yeah that you said the
tranquility can it just instantly kills
you though here we go here we go two
minutes and 33 seconds I say they're
gonna get it but who's they
you struggle though oh what a waste yeah
Oh Kira man oh they gotta they brought
out the Bastion
that's fine yeah that way Tetsuo
where are you cut it ahh oh my god yeah
what's up death of Astra
Oh make him pay for it
yep yep all the bastions around here
somewhere assume remember how I said you
guys might be in trouble oh he's up top
I should not be over there by yourself
okay this is getting kind of hairy group
up bashing hard counter I find like more
flanking options would do this Oh like
that feel good about this
you have meteor strike okay I'm gonna
wait till they get a little bit closer
all that bastion huh okay no maybe you
just stay there maybe you just stay
there oh that's bad
okay we're still good Oh get out of here
doofus oh you got Genji - OH
dragon wagon well we still got vivan the
point one meter you can do it officer
Deva yeah you got it
opera diva whoo all right now you got
defend with your life
Akira whoa
he's gonna walk did he really do
he just he just the last to soldier
played the plays of the game had just
been him just shooting they don't want
the salty runback is that close you got
to do the run batter like I'm how our
whole team is just like yeah let's do it
again that's right I should have I think
can you still do it he's still farm for
offers to Deva that's past huh I think
it's only when they do the skin thing
again no no I thought they they put it
into the game oh did they yeah they put
they put it in like as like a random
drop I think but if you like wanted to
just get it right away then you could do
the yeah no that's over yeah just that
it if you still if you wanna right now
you can it's just gonna take you a while
to get through leap boxes but if they
bring it back then you can get it again
right yeah brought it back the first
time you could get Oni if you just play
it oh yeah we haven't had a chance to
look at it yet but the the loot box
changes in this patch they've made it so
that you don't get deep no you don't get
dupes hardly anymore like I opened up a
couple boxes last or 2 days ago and all
four of them were new or all four before
both boxes were new which is it feels
nice not to see the gold pop up every
time yeah and feel bad yeah but what we
need is it's actually interesting that
they they didn't roll that loop box
update out with like an event yeah cuz
it would have been more interesting to
see what that's like because it always
feels bad when you kind of get the old
yeah it gives like 30 or 50 new summer
games boxes and you still get like a
boat I want an America McCrea wait no
maybe I did get America McCrea it was a
me hongan-ji that I really want
but then I got like metal gear rising or
metal gear revengeance uh all right so
we got doomed is here so we can go with
like okay so you got a counter it C was
a good one tank
sadly see we got sorry azaria they have
like her new new old maybe I think Farah
was pretty fun against come on go also
hard for him to do tracer to like I was
able to you this skins great yeah I like
this well that's great
it's like that paintballing one right
sort of yeah or like the graffiti so
like your spree
she's like spray cans their guns it's
always interesting I mean like I feel
like sometimes they just put so much
more detail on some of the the
legendaries than other ones yeah that's
like all things aren't created well
tracer has like what she's got a
legendary or something like a skin in
every event because she's like the
poster child for the game that's a good
point goob I kind of missed out on the
Yeti Winston that's a pretty good one to
be honest but I went Nutcracker Zenyatta
I had to all right I'll give you another
what's up death of Astra thanks for
tuning in for a new test we started off
on a on a somewhat sour note because I'm
what you wrote that I didn't need but I
think we're on good terms that's why
it's about forging that relationship you
know wait right here I like it
wait for the doofus know you can see
this is a player unknown battlegrounds
tat level time here don't forget Mondays
that's a good time again Mondays player
I know battlegrounds with Mike so make
sure to tune into that cuz they will be
playing every Monday for a while it
worked for a while until the joke right
turn early dude double-team second so
hum see you a hard where the changes
made in the news patch there's a lot
there was character balance I can try to
pull up the list for you again
let's let's take a look real quick there
was a highlight options that Joey had
mentioned you can kind of save up to
three I believe yeah three three every
match sorry every match you can export
it at different resolutions which is
nice obviously you can also I think you
said save other people's plays of the
game plays of the game so pretty good
stuff obviously and then let's see what
else do we have obviously if you missus
in there we also just talked about the
the loot the loot boxes and how you're
probably gonna see less dupes in general
and then there's a bunch of character
balances that you know I could read
along with oh oh we have no healer good
oh we know we do the other he's all the
way back here this isn't doofus yeah
unfortunately Chris Anderson there's a
first match where someone are actually
someone else actually picked tomb fist I
do this now oh they switch stuff laptop
okay so we're back speak of the devil
but yeah he was trying some doofus
esque counters but I go downstairs this
I can go downstairs but they even have a
dude oh yes [ __ ] and I'm kidding then I
have 300 health oh good night Oh low
supporters run oh no yeah get out of
here we just killed four I'm gonna save
that save that we're gonna watch it
after two cuz that was that was nice
what's up in etosha miller says they're
new to the stream welcome welcome thanks
for tuning in we just got ginger I was
like a mini quad like nada not a true
quad but like a mini quad
they don't want to go down that corridor
you dare them Oh following me
I think I poked my head out and he came
after me recently yeah their gang is
waiting for a while only when it makes
sense a goober saying we're now do
fist-sized African not tegus though oh
oh he's sidestep oh gosh just jumping
all over the place
or he's IRA Singh instead of the
tranquility okay dude that one corridor
that you got those yeah there's this all
stuck in there will they lining up oh
yes well ma'am over here I can make that
gap so one or two Superman too many
angles oh no you got bork bork bork try
that again
it's coming a meteor fake oh wait burn
wafer majalis all the way over there Oh
No Oh dare you how dare you
who was they'll so far up not today mr.
yeah I can't tell kanji kanji yeah its
kanji so it's tough it's definitely not
Korean though I don't think man quad
kill skills
that's correct Liz names quad Christo's
I love a good old quad feet yeah I love
a quad feet - okay good this oh how did
that not kill the Genji they flew in
that doesn't make sense to me alright my
face unless it was behind your sort yeah
something like that
or contestants that seems pretty dirty
though to go through yeah I know cuz
like because there's that window up
there yeah yeah
is that really the only reason why
though yeah if there's like any opening
you can you can get through it you know
I start doing that common war it's like
don't you don't want to rock a punch in
first you want to like do the slam first
and then the uppercut and then rock a
punch them in the ass they come midair
yeah cuz they're vulnerable right yeah
it doesn't I think it it's like cuz when
you rock watch them first it knocks them
back Oh what I read or he just happened
to be running away he showed you exactly
what he meant
I still think Joey's crazy I am here you
guys do like three people as a warm-up I
just like being lame prove upon in the
range it's getting you in their face
see watch he's gonna always study how he
musta did it first but I sense oh no I
think we like both gone knock down one
junk right yeah put some traps down oh
nice there you go you put them
Oh justice sweet justice there's one
person there it's again jeez he's ko
King
oh yeah meat here you just do that to
get them yeah
oh but argh Angie come on yeah metal
gear revengeance no it's okay he was the
last one okay yeah yeah definitely push
them off the payload oh man you got to
hold it for three minutes yeah we're
good stay tuned this is my waifu for 100
cool points but even though I said that
he's not my waifu though mais my waifu -
Angie :
you'll see push them back at least I'm
gonna try that again
oh that was good
all right it got nobody would Giuliana
plays yeah nice yeah so you pretty much
like after you get that punch off you
want to try to like line up that fat
sick that secondary fire Oh team kill oh
he was waiting
what's up over plays how you doing
unfortunately we don't do too much of
tympanum channels but definitely will
give you a shout out though oh can I get
up there question is can you get a big
hole to end the stream with the hope
that maybe you get that quad kill key
but why is everyone in here yeah I mean
that was another one of those doom halls
it get her oh she has she has a general
I thought she was gonna use it yeah
words a minute
13% all right they're going down I
slowly hope they're behind you you can
be what how'd I miss
oh this bad
why is it bad oh meteor shake where the
Ginji go you 1% to all hold on to this
you're just doing that to stall I think
if you have no choice now is it times
he's one shot this one back in oh no we
still mostly mostly alive yeah you're
gonna get a soldier there I know
ducked out of the way at the last second
mm yep they're on the shame to here
we're you will be ok oh ok uppercutted
mash uppercut on wake up
yeah
nice all right I always get to go out on
a win and he gets got that highlight to
them hopefully is it play we get it well
I got it saved it I'm not sure if that
what that was like play of the game or
anything oh of course it was justice
terrible justice was oh this is where I
came in I think I was trying to back up
yeah I was trying to back them up but
she already killed like two people there
first
yeah all right we'll just watch our own
we'll show the highlights because that's
something you can do now yeah so under
this little menu right here highlights
doing this here so you can watch it do
you think it oh it clips it after you
clip it yeah
we're playing on PC you guys right now
um so it also will just automatically
clip like you know before it would have
like your five top plays just
automatically found you'll go back in so
then you can record that and be like
okay I want to have it be at 4k 4k
supers three times super simple 60
frames per second alter quality and
people or disable music and you just
record it and then it'll like take a
little bit well I guess the file is only
like 15 seconds long so I guess it's
like oh no does this just kidding and
that's where we go to camera to say
goodbye I'm so lasting obviously I'm
Eric that's Joey thanks everyone for
watching we really appreciate it
we are always streaming all not always
five days a week every day at 11:00
tomorrow we're gonna have the lobby
where is our weekly chat and discussion
of big news and reviews and things like
that so make sure you tune into that
make sure you like follow and subscribe
so you get notified for all those
streams as well as cool blog content
last time we're gonna kind of pimp
Joey's do fist Hiro guide we have a
bunch of Hiro guide so it's not just
doing fist if you're just getting into
overwatch it's a great way to kind of
learn about the hero's and some of the
things are good at doing and some of the
things that they're weak against
and also there's like a small like
doofus highlight game play where Joey
kind of shows you some of the counter
heroes to doofus so if you're curious
who counters doofus there's also that on
our YouTube so thanks again thank you
Joey
thanks for having me any any final
thoughts and you're you're probably last
do pissed I don't know about thoughts
but will be I would be playing them
throughout the week just to get better
for the next stream hopefully it'll be
the Summer Games
so if whenever that releases we're not
sure quite yet but it's coming
I'm sure thanks again thanks Liz for the
kind words as well that's the vastra
thank you guys we'll see you guys next
time